I think that there is no one perfect way to do this.
I've somehow taken in the idea that there is a perfect way to do this.
Everybody wants to be the best parent.
Everybody wants to raise this perfect kid.
The hardest thing about parenting for me is...
...knowing if I have given or done enough for them every day.
Am I pushing them too hard?
Am I not pushing them hard enough?
I always feel like he deserves more than I can give him.
You know, I wish I could be like, home at 4:00, making a gourmet meal...
..and we'd all sit down.
And it's difficult to look back and think, "Wow, I should have been there."
I worry that he's gonna grow out of me,...
...that there's not gonna be time.
You're never gonna feel like you were doing it right, because it's too important.
I just want them to know I'm really trying, I'm really, really trying, you know.
She's like, the best and she like, holds our family together.
No, I mean he's like, a great dad, not like so-so.
I hope to be half of the mom that she is because she set the standards really high.
I'm trying not to cry honestly because talking about her...
When I say she's my heart, she means the world to me.
I'm the luckiest for a lot of reasons but my parents being the top two.
She has a pure heart and cares about people.
I love you so much.
I think my daddy's great.